yeah
and now they're a business expense
exactly very nice well you know the
movie it is so huge yeah yeah I think
they came out with this coffee table
book because they thought the movie it
was coming out but it just didn't sell
this is a coffee table book called last
place in the world you'd want to see a
clown and I thought yeah it's just it
didn't really no thanks
yeah it's just a bunch of scenarios I
guess the whole book yeah
and then finally that's not work as I'm
leaving this world then this one came
out can't believe no one wanted this one
it's called why did shaq endorse that
and it's just a lot of products I don't
know I like that last one here's one
that didn't sell you can probably see
why it's called New Zealand with the
lens cap still on just Queenstown and
then right that's the whole book there's
peanut beach every single page Wow yeah
here's sort of a celebrity based one
seems a little random maybe that's why I
didn't smell Danny Trejo rates letters
there he is giving you like he likes Al
I'm not a fan of P oh he likes oh and no
not fan of a yeah wonder why yeah I like
people watching this one thinking I bet
it gets even funnier
as we go along you know a nice tuck with
and then towards the end no it doesn't
he just doesn't like a he doesn't like a
yeah but this one this one
you gotta love it's called earthworms
making small talk check it out look at
that that tasted like dirt this is an
interesting one was that dirt or poop
it's always it's her and then well time
to go have sex with myself yeah and it
covers it they can do that as can i all
right now listen this is just man this
one is interesting it's just this is it
this is all it is it's called it's
called jean-claude Van Damme
that's all it is at least he's flexible
hey get me outta here
you know I'm a presidential history buff
that's why I got this last one it's
called forgotten presidential scandals
these are presidential scandals that
have been forgotten how could this not
sell I know
look at this David Bowie in bed with
Jimmy Carter right I never want to hear
that there's a Nixon feeding a hippie to
a crocodile and find the FDR jump in the
Potomac in a rocket-powered wheelchair
[Applause]
you